يجب أن تكون هناك دعوة جماعية لوقف
إطلاق النار وأنا أعلم أن بعض الذين هم
ضد وقف إطلاق النار جنوب شرقي يقولون أنه
سيساعد حماس ولكني أشعر أنهم
في تلك الحجة
يرفضون بطبيعتهم أه الموت بل في الحقيقة
يؤيدون ويبررون  مقتل
الآلاف من المدنيين، وهذا أمر يستحق الشجب
أخلاقيا، كما أنه
قصير النظر وغير عقلاني تماما
لأنه كما قلت من قبل، تعرف إذا
تمكنت من القضاء على حماس بأكملها،
فما هو السبب الجذري التالي لهذا
الصراع هو الاحتلال غير القانوني؟
أه انتهاكات روتينية لحقوق الإنسان أه
مستوطنات غير شرعية أه أم تجاهل
لقرارات الأمم المتحدة والقانون الدولي إذا
لم نعالج هذه الأسباب الجذرية
فيمكنك قتل المقاتل لكن
لا يمكنك قتل القضية وعلى أنقاض
هذه المباني المدمرة ستظهر
مجموعة أخرى المزيد  عازمة وأكثر
حماسا للقيام بما فعلته حماس، لذلك
أعتقد أن إسرائيل بحاجة إلى أن تدرك مرة واحدة وإلى الأبد
أنها إذا أرادت أمنها فإن
أفضل طريق هو من خلال السلام، فأنت
لا تعرف أقوى جيش أو
أجهزة استخبارات أكثر قدرة أو
القبة الحديدية  أو أن الجدار العازل
سيحمي أمن إسرائيل بقدر
ما سيحميه السلام، وأعتقد أن هذا هو
المسار الذي نحتاج إلى اتباعه الآن.
كان وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين
في الأردن خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ويقول
إن
لإسرائيل كل الحق في الاستقلال الذاتي.  الدفاع
للدفاع عن نفسه ضمن أه قواعد
الحرب لكي نضمن أن ما
حدث في 7 أكتوبر لن يتكرر
مرة أخرى إذا أردنا التأكد من أننا
لن نكون في هذا الوضع مرة أخرى
علينا أن نسأل أنفسنا كيف وصلنا إلى
هناك  يجب أن يكون إذا
وقف العنف بين الفلسطينيين وبين
مستقبل أفضل فإنهم هم أنفسهم
سيحاربون هذا العنف
أريد فقط أن أعطيكم حقيقة واحدة بسيطة أه أه
بعد اتفاقيات أوسلو عام
1993 في عام 1996 تم إجراء استطلاع للرأي
وأظهر أن 80  النسبة المئوية للفلسطينيين
أيدوا الاتفاقات
وانخفض دعم المقاومة العنيفة إلى
20%، لذلك إذا كان لدى الفلسطينيين
أفق سياسي فإنهم هم أنفسهم سيكونون ضد
أي شكل من أشكال العنف ولكن يجب أن
يعطوا هذا الاحتمال. ما مدى قلقك
بشأن عدد القتلى المدنيين
وتفاقمه؟  الوضع الإنساني على
الأرض في غزة وما هي الخطوات الحقيقية، إن
وجدت، التي ترى إسرائيل تتخذها لتقليل
الخسائر البشرية؟ لا أستطيع أن أبدأ في وصف
حجم ونطاق
الوضع الإنساني الكارثي
الذي نشهده، وهو أمر
غير مسبوق على الإطلاق، وكان لا يطاق
شاهد الانهيار الجليدي
للمعاناة الإنسانية حيث نرى ما يقرب من
10000 حالة وفاة أه نصفهم تقريبًا من
الأطفال، وإذا وضعت ذلك في
الاعتبار خلال الأسابيع الأربعة الماضية في
غزة، فقد قُتل ثمانية أضعاف عدد الأطفال الذين
قُتلوا خلال العشرين شهرًا من
الحرب الأوكرانية  لقد أطلقت اليونيسيف على غزة اسم "
ساحة القبر أه للأطفال" وأنت تعلم أن
هذه ليست مجرد أرقام، كل واحد من
هؤلاء الأطفال كان كل شيء لشخص ما
الآن هناك اختصار في غزة WC
tnsf طفل جريح بدون عائلة على قيد الحياة
هذا اختصار لا ينبغي أن يكون
موجودًا أبدًا ولكنه  هل يوجد في غزة، كما تعلمون،
أعتقد أن العالم
يصرخ فقط عندما يكون عدد الأشخاص الذين يجب أن
يموتوا قبل أن يستيقظ ضميرنا العالمي
أم أنه يظل نائماً إلى الأبد عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالفلسطينيين،
يصر الإسرائيليون على أنهم يبذلون قصارى جهدهم
لحماية المواطنين حتى الآن  يقولون أن حماس تستخدم
المواطنين كدروع بشرية والمواقع التي
تقول إنها أمثلة عديدة على
استخدام الجماعة الإرهابية دروعًا بشرية في هذا
الصراع الحالي، ما رأيك في ذلك
حسنًا انظر أه بعد مقتل أكثر من 10000
شخص 70٪ منهم نساء
وأطفال من أجل  ادعاء الإسرائيليين أنهم
يحاولون حماية مواطني CI،
كما تعلمون بصراحة، إنها إهانة
للمخابرات عندما أه 1.1
مليون شخص يطلبون مغادرة
منازلهم أو المخاطرة بالموت، وهذا ليس
حماية للمدنيين والتهجير القسري
و  وكالات الأمم المتحدة ووكالات أخرى
قالت أنه لا يوجد
مكان آمن أه في غزة وحتى المناطق التي
طلبوا من الناس اللجوء إليها في
تلك ما يسمى بالمناطق الآمنة
تم الهجوم عليهم أيضا ولا يهمهم
أن يتم إرسال أوامر الإخلاء
على الإنترنت أو على شاشة التلفزيون مع العلم
أنه لا توجد كهرباء في غزة
منذ بداية هذه الحرب،
لا أعتقد أن أوامر الإخلاء هذه
لصالح المدنيين في غزة، فهم
ليسوا الجمهور المستهدف
لبقية العالم  إنها
محاولة إسرائيلية لمحاولة إضفاء الشرعية على
أفعالها، وعندما يتعلق الأمر
بالدروع البشرية، أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى الإذعان
للقانون الدولي بالطبع، فإن استخدام
الدروع البشرية يعد عملاً إجراميًا، ولكن حتى لو
استخدمه أحد الأطراف فإنه يعرض
مدنيًا للخطر.  لا يزال
يحق للدولة الحصول على الحماية الكاملة بموجب
القانون الإنساني الدولي الذي يمثل
المعيار العالمي ولا
تستثني أي دولة، لذلك قبل إطلاق أي رصاصة
قبل إسقاط أي قنبلة، تقع على
عاتق الدولة مسؤولية تقييم
المخاطر التي تهدد حياة المدنيين، وإذا كان هذا
الخطر غير متناسب  إلى أه
للهدف العسكري فهو
غير قانوني وبصراحة أجد أنه أمر
شائن حقًا عندما يقوم المسؤولون الإسرائيليون
بجرأة باستبعاد
الضحايا الفلسطينيين باعتبارهم دروعًا بشرية في
مكان مثل جباليا وهي من
أكثر أركان غزة ازدحامًا أه غزة
كونها واحدة من  إن موت المدنيين في المناطق الأكثر كثافة سكانية
على وجه
الأرض ليس عرضيًا،
وليس عرضيًا، بل هو
نتيجة حتمية وهذا يجعلها جريمة حرب،
فنحن نشهد
ارتفاعًا كبيرًا في معاداة السامية في الولايات المتحدة
وخاصة في حرم الجامعات لدينا.
شهدت أيضًا ارتفاعًا كبيرًا في
كراهية الإسلام والهجمات على
الطلاب المسلمين مع تزايد الكراهية والخوف، ما مدى
قلقك وما الذي يجب فعله لخفض
درجة الحرارة
الآن، أريد أن
أدين معاداة
السامية وكراهية الإسلام بشكل مطلق ومن كل قلبي، إنه ليس كذلك
أبدًا  حسنًا، ليس من المبرر أبدًا
مهاجمة شخص ما بناءً على
معتقداته السياسية ولكن أريد أيضًا أن أذكر
الجميع بأن إسرائيل لا تمثل
كل الشعب اليهودي حول العالم
أه إسرائيل دولة وهي وحدها
المسؤولة عن جرائمها أه
الشعب اليهودي في جميع أنحاء العالم  في العالم، الكثير منهم
مرعوبون مما يرونه وأه كما
تعلم كما قلت، الإسلاموفوبيا هي
الوجه الآخر لنفس المرض ونحن
أه المسلمين يجب أن نكون أول من
يدين أه معاداة السامية لدينا
تاريخ طويل  من التعايش السلمي لذلك الأمر
لا يتعلق بالدين بل يتعلق
بالسياسة وما رأيناه أه في
السنوات الأخيرة أه هو تهمة معاداة
السامية التي يتم استخدامها كسلاح من أجل
إسكات أي انتقاد لإسرائيل أه لذلك
المدافعين أو المؤيدين لإسرائيل الذين
لا يمكنهم الدفاع عن تصرفات إسرائيل أو
سلوكها الذي يعودون إليه، فهم يعودون إلى
إغلاق المحادثة من خلال
تعريف انتقادات إسرائيل بمعاداة
السامية، دعني أكون واضحًا جدًا،
كونك مؤيدًا للفلسطينيين ليس
معاديًا للسامية، كونك مؤيدًا للفلسطينيين
لا يعني أنك مؤيد للفلسطينيين.  - حماس أو مؤيدي
الإرهاب أعتقد أن إسرائيل تستحق
من حلفائها أكثر من مجرد أه أه
دعم لا لبس فيه أعتقد أنها تستحق
بعض الحقائق غير المريحة لأنه إذا
كنت صديقًا حقيقيًا فإنك تدعم
صديقك عندما يكون على حق ولكنك أيضًا
تخبره عندما يكون''  لقد عبرت الخط